go to the city
tell them i'm here tell them i'm back
i came the long way around
[Music]
okay here's the one that you've all been
waiting for and i have been dreading
hell bent
now i suppose i should set expectations
this is probably not going to be as
shouty as uh some
viewers were probably hoping that would
be given that
the last time i talked explicitly about
this episode
oh [ __ ] you moffat yeah i
got a little worked up but the thing is
this time
i came in with my analytical brain in
place
i was trying to figure out what
is this why is this
and why does it not work because
even coming in at my most open minded
having watched and gone out of my way to
look at all the build up that
came in the series up to this point
building to the decisions that are made
in this and it
still doesn't work well i gotta figure
out why not
because it's not like the work wasn't
put in
there was plenty of work put in to build
up
and really hammer in on the fact
that clara is being too reckless
that she being in danger pushes the
doctor
in ways that isn't probably a good idea
for him they
are mutually toxic not in a standard
toxic relationship way of being mean to
each other
but just bringing out things out of each
of them that is just not
good so that was done and with that leg
work done
this should work because the heart of
this the core of this
is what extremes is the doctor willing
to go to
in order to save clara oh wow that's
pretty bad
maybe maybe somebody needs to put a stop
to this that's what it's trying to do
and it does actually do that but somehow
even though it built it up over the
series and it delivers on that specific
element it still
falls apart right from the opening the
fact
that heaven sent ends with the reveal of
gallifrey
he's found gallifrey and he's
pissed and what is hell bent open with
a truck in the desert
pulling up to a diner this does a lot
to diffuse the inherent
tension and the anxiety and the oh
what's gonna happen
this this is this is why 95
of the time at least 95 of the time no
story benefits from a flash forward
i mean i say no like very rarely
but i cannot think of too many stories
where it benefits that you jump ahead to
later
because you lose the momentum you lose
the tension and yes
there's a delay between episodes anyway
so there's a there's gonna be a lot but
completely shifting gears like this
i'm completely out of the headspace you
put me into from heaven
which honestly
here's a here's a weird thing you know
what would make
hell bent work a lot better
if heaven sent didn't exist
and i don't just mean that because of
the natural comparison
that they are the episodes immediately
next to each other so
almost anything is going to look bad in
comparison to heaven sent no
i mean that that what heaven sent is
doing and what hell bent is doing
are inherently at odds fundamentally
again and i said this at the end of my
heaven sound review unless i completely
misinterpreted what it is that heaven
sent is doing
and i don't think i did
but unless unless that happened unless i
completely missed the point of heaven
sent
and not only completely missed it but
fell in love with an interpretation that
wasn't the intended one
unless that's what happened these two do
not gel
they just don't because as i said heaven
sent
is all about grief
but it's about not succumbing
to grief it is about battling it and how
long that feels like it takes day after
day after day
as you chip away at this pain to try and
be able just to live
again following a massive loss and
clara's exact words to him are
get over it he appears to or as much as
he's going to
in a healthy way and then he comes into
this and immediately pulls
utter [ __ ]
oh so let's talk about the doctor's
actions specifically here's the one
thing that he does that i actually think
is really cool
i love that he sets up shop in this
barn and just ignores everyone who comes
to him
that isn't wrasslon this soldier in a
ship
shows up he ignores them
a whole lot of them including a
high-ranking general
shows up ignores them rathalon shows up
okay
now we'll talk i like that his
demanding of getting the attention of
the person he wants to talk to
i do like that that having been said
again i keep coming back to the fact
that the doctor's actions and the
extremes that he goes to
to save clara would feel
much more justified if they weren't
coming on the heels of heaven sent
and what that episode was doing if that
episode didn't happen if we had gone
directly from face the raven
into hell bent i could i
may i probably wouldn't still like it
like
in all honesty but i could swallow
better
the lengths that the doctor goes to the
fact that he
shoots somebody yes that person then
regenerates but he just
shoots them dead i'm really not okay
with it
oh and like he regenerates into a woman
and not only that regenerates into a
woman with significant amount of
eyeliner on
really makeup's part of the regeneration
great
wonderful i don't know why that really
annoyed me
but i noticed that this time but
you know that he's endangering
everything
she's been dead for half the lifetime of
the universe
if you try to change that you could
fracture time itself
and again there was all this
build up prior to this but the thing is
here's the other part of the problem and
again it would have worked better coming
out face the raven
but here's the thing both halves of all
the buildup that went on
in series nine have already paid off
before this episode starts clara's half
pays off
and face the raven when her decisions
and her attempts to be like the doctor
get her killed and the doctors half of
it
dealing with the fact that he had
wrapped up so much of himself in her
specifically
and how much he just wanted to quit and
lay down and die
when he realized that she was gone but
he still has to get up and
keep carrying on anyway that was all
dealt with in heaven sent
so we've dealt with both halves of the
equation and everything already feels
paid off and then we have hell bent
trying to repay off the same stuff
in a different way after we had very
satisfying payoffs for all of it
i don't get it like
and like i mean that legitimately i've
this is now
this is now the third video i'm devoting
specifically to this episode i still
don't get it
and i don't mean like i don't get what
the episode is doing i think i
do but i don't get why you would do it
if you already did the stuff that
happened in face the raven and heaven
sent
why would you try and do this why would
you try and do this story that is all
about
the extremes the doctor is going to go
to and how
he's completely off off the deep end
about this one person
why it this doesn't flow
and i i also have fundamental
philosophical issues with that
um because and i i've brought this up
before this was
this was what i yelled about i'm not
as harsh on this as i used to be but
there's still an element of it there
which is this whole bigging up of clara
the doctor has not done this or anything
close to this for any
other companion including ones that have
died he's never been willing to go to
these
lengths and part of what that
does intended or not is imply that
clara is somehow more important than
every other companion who has ever
traveled in the tardis because he
didn't do this for anyone else now
i i say i'm a little lighter on that
than i used to be because i i
hammered on that and i'm not entirely
convinced it's intentional
i do think that stephen moffat fell in
love with
his character i absolutely do believe
that but
i'm willing to accept the possibility
that he may not have been deliberately
trying to
make her the most important companion in
the history of doctor who
however that is still implied by what's
going on and this is something that i've
run into
with doctor who and with the other stuff
as well where
the writers don't think through the
implication of what they're doing and
sometimes it's the implications that
piss me off
and that's kind of the case here but
like i said i'm not going to hit that as
hard as i have
before but it's in there and it's one
more thing that's in the mix
and then here's what's really bizarre to
me
if you're doing that story the story of
the doctor going too far to save someone
who is who died and accepted their death
why are you also tying off
the rediscovery of gallifrey and rasalon
why why is all of this
well why at all with it and why is it
sharing space with this story
they don't blend they don't
complement each other this has nothing
to do with this
and the fact that rascal wrassle on
regardless of whether you like what
happened with him
in the end of time this is a character
who was intimidating he was threatening
the destruction of the entire universe
all of time and space
basically just gets told go in the
corner and think about what you did and
is gone
halfway through why
like philosophically i kind of like the
idea
of this influential
powerful person
basically ultimately coming across as an
impotent
old man who just doesn't have power
anymore
philosophically i like that idea but
it's so
sidelined by the stuff going on with
clara
that i don't know why it's here i don't
know why rastalon was brought back at
all
and all respect to the actor because i
actually do like this actor
i can't remember his name now but he's
no timothy dalton
timothy dalton commanded the screen this
guy doesn't and again i can kind of
philosophically get behind the idea of
well
he's not the grand and mighty thing he
you know projects himself to be
but again that has nothing to do with
clara's story
it literally gets ignored and brushed
away and shoot off
and with all the build up
about the idea of finding gallifrey
again
the build-up ever since day of the
doctor
the idea that one day he would find it
again the joy on his face that the idea
that he find it
the fury that he experienced when he
realized that missy gave him coordinates
that went nowhere and he didn't find it
again
he found it and the fact that he found
gallivard again has absolutely nothing
to do with the story because he
single-mindedly focused on clara
you could find a way to make the point
that he is single-mindedly focused on
on helping clara without burning off
massive story developments that moffat
himself set up
that i don't get at all like it would
make sense to me
if day of the doctor or the events of
that you know with california
and what happened with it there had
happened under davies watch
and moffat kind of felt like he was
stuck with that
and like because it that's what it feels
like it feels like the kind of we gotta
we gotta tie this up so that people
don't ask me anymore i can now do my own
thing
but this was his own concept this was
his
thing and he just balls it up throws it
away okay heck with that
why actually you know what the word why
is the buzzword for this entire
episode goes back to that barn
again from listen and from day of the
doctor
why apparently because it's the only
it's the only piece of iconography we
have for gallifrey other than the dome
city
evidently the gallifriends who aren't
time lords
look like they belong in little house of
the prairie
why like there's this implication that
you know they're simpler people like
their farmers or something first of all
it's a freaking desert nobody's
farming anything and second of all even
if they
are in some way a lower class a more
simple rural
um or you know just not living the kind
of life the time lords are that's fine
why do they look like they belong on
earth
in the dust bowl circa 1918
they shouldn't look like they're from
earth
i'm not talking about looking you up
talking about the clothes
why and then there's the whole hybrid
thing
why why do the time lords think the
doctor knows about the hybrid
that kicks off literally everything the
fact that they're trying to get that
confession out of him
why do they think he knows anything
never established
in this it's not even firmly established
that the doctor
does know anything about the hybrid now
that does somewhat get addressed and it
also answered another question that i
had
because i had i have not re-watched this
for a long time
you can imagine why so
the doctor admits later on that he
has been playing them basically as soon
as he realized he was in a confession
dial
he had been letting them believe
that he knew what the hybrid is because
if if it was known that he didn't they
might never let him
out so he had to hold on to that
and pretend like he knew and then you
know play his cards really close to the
chest until he could get to that
room the whatever the heck they called
it so that he could pull clara out of
her time stream
so that was his goal the entire time
all the stuff with razzle on all the
stuff everything else that had gone on
up to that point
was all a front and he had been faking
that
wow he may well have been thinking that
he knew anything about the hybrid in the
first place but i still come back to the
same question
why did the why do the time lords think
that he does
and also you know what is the hybrid
there are multiple things floated and
suggested
and a primary thing pointed
to but not
definitively which is probably why some
people have said that part of what
timeless children was doing was
tying up the hybrid thing although i
don't think that was intended because
they don't explicitly draw that
connection
i i think if chibnall wanted it to be
that he would have made it more explicit
but the the hybrid
it's implied that it could be a shielder
it is
implied that it could be the doctor it's
implied that it could be
the doctor and clara that the hybrid is
not one being but
two and that's the thing that it leans
on most heavily
but it also says that the hybrid will
stand in the smoking ruins of gallifrey
that doesn't flip and happen so what
the hell there's no real
answer to this and it could have been
brushed off
better if it hadn't been if either
either it hadn't been the recurring
thing that gets brought up across the
entire series
or if it had not been hammered so hard
in this episode itself one of those
needed to back off
because when you put this much emphasis
on it
across the series and here now
you can not just be like
it doesn't matter you can't you put
you put too much emphasis on it to get
away with that back off in either one of
those
then you could have gotten away with it
doesn't matter but you you bigged it up
too much
no you don't get to do that and realize
i say that
not even really caring i don't care
but you still blew it speaking of things
we don't get an explanation of
that also brush by what how gallifrey
even
got out of whatever little pocket
universe it was in it's literally a
toss-off line the line the doctor has is
well it's unfroze
unfrozen and now it's back again like
this should be
this should matter tossed off one line
also add to the pile of why the cloister
rates
these things that are there for
wantable monsters i've i've run into
this before with doctor who
some stories don't need a monster no
monster required so what the hell are
the cloister wraiths
and why why are the cloister rates and
why is it
feel vaguely implied that they are
somehow tied to the
to the weeping angels maybe that's just
me i don't know it's dumb either way
because there's no point
and again if it was just a background
feature that'd be one thing but they get
named
repeatedly attention gets drawn to them
so enough attention is drawn to the
things that they should matter to this
story but they
don't if you had dialed it back maybe
they could have been furniture
maybe they could have been a background
world building feature but again
like the hybrid itself you drew too much
attention to it
and you're not doing anything with it oh
and as a bonus i
never ever want to hear anybody again
tell me that part of the purpose of the
timeless children was to remove the
regeneration limit
for the doctor you didn't have to you
know why there's a line in this
stupid freaking episode where rosalind
says
how many regenerations did we grant you
i've got all night he flat out admits
that
they gave him more than just a standard
set of regenerations
and there isn't a number on it you
didn't need to grant the doctor
effectively infinite okay now i'm
getting mad about a completely different
episode that's not helping
i said i wasn't gonna get shouty i lied
the only thing
the only thing that works insofar as it
is not
completely undermined by the other stuff
that fails
is the conversation between the doctor
and clara in the tardis prior to the
mind wipe
the discomfort of that
the fact that in this may or may not
have been intended but it's kind of
invoking what happened to donna a little
bit because
clara would rather die than lose her
memories
it's a decent scene and honestly
actually you know what
i'll cop to this all the problems with
this
acting is not the issue capaldi's
working his butt off
clara's doing her best wrestle on he
didn't work
but the guy was trying sisters a car
don't know why they're there
but they're well performed i try and be
fair
in terms of where to put the blame and
it's not on the actors actors did fine
it's the writing it's the script
what this thing was doing
doesn't work doesn't gel
with the series overall doesn't function
well within itself
it is trying simultaneously to do too
many things
while at the same time its primary focus
thing didn't work on
concept alone based off where we just
were last episode
i do know that some people like this
episode i know that
i know that they're they show up in my
comments they've explained to me in the
past what it is they like about it
and i've tried to understand that and i
can even understand some of the things
they say
but nothing i have ever heard in defense
of this episode
negates the issues that i see
it is a tonal mess
it doesn't flow well off of heaven sent
at all it doesn't pay off the
season-long stuff
not any better than the previous two
episodes did anyway at least as far as
the emotional stuff goes and the
logistical stuff it doesn't even pay off
at all
it doesn't properly pay off gallifrey
not in a way that's satisfying
it brings back rats a lot in a way that
has zero catharsis
whatsoever it doesn't properly pay off
the whole idea of the hybrid
it just doesn't work
it doesn't if it works for you
then i'm jealous because i don't like
getting this worked up
i know you folks do you get
entertainment out of it i don't i
it's not actually fun for me to hate
things
i don't enjoy especially an episode of a
tv show that i
love an episode coming off of one of my
favorite episodes of new era doctor who
and i hate it i hate it
so much
hell bent have you re-watched it lately
why
but if you did what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
a bunch of stuff to do like share
subscribe
i have a patreon if you want to help pay
for my
that'd therapy greatly appreciated uh
links to other stuff i've got merch and
usual things whatever
uh links in the description
you don't have to do any of it though i
don't have the strength
to even plead beyond that because
at the end of the day you're the council
i just run these meetings and until next
time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh